nine [ __ ] with the host you own your
own baby down there that's true that's a
month that's true among old I can't feed
after you the tentacles the field they
have no eyes to talk them that little
sunlight they got a lake in Georgia that
people just my students are always dying
disappear not as real [ __ ] like I don't
know my friends was a lifeguard jumping
that would anticipate what what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
hot boxing with Mike Tyson I'm ever
Britton and I might Tyson Mike we got a
great guest bro I think I thought this
dude was one of the [ __ ] Raiders
walking in yeah my you know that's the
Menem one thing for Batman with this
[ __ ] big what do you do man you eat a
lot huh
yeah I'm a country boy Waka Flocka
welcome brother how are you doing about
this welcome let's show Mel I got big
because I start eating pescetarian man
oh really
yeah I realized yeah did some fish in
yeah I realize wait so did you go you
went full vegan yeah you know what vegan
was calling me that I love they start
making me like this big as poster boy
uh-huh yeah but something that truly
ain't have I know you can't be called
something you ain't due for five years
hmm you know a lot of people eat one
away for six months eight months nine
months you call yourself a stone-cold
vegan like it's impossible
I give me five months to actually be who
you are you dig what I'm saying so when
I start like they like oh he's vegan
things I drink and other people will be
around me you know because people be
toxic as folks you gotta be careful
about everything
yeah everything brother oh that's well
said no definitely so what brought you
to being mindful about your eating being
conscious of what you're putting in your
body [ __ ] my pants a photo
I'm weighing three ex foliate shirts
yeah I'm 315 320 Wow oh I'm looking like
a true linebacker
also my brothers I got a DTaP oh yeah
for sure bro like cuz I was 325 myself
come on my boy you know how does it feel
oh yeah
then you breathing heavy watching TV
folks yes we are you sleeping
yeah well you can't [ __ ] you constipated
sometimes but I am NOT eating food again
there Mike you'd you've been pretty
heavy in your deck yeah cuz I was I'm
addicts food is the drug pills I get
consumed with I mean I kids gonna film
and try to kill myself for food is food
is one of the most powerful drugs now
especially nowadays believe yet do you
believe this is conscious of your
existence
I need to live you need to eat to live
I'm in the beginning of a 72-hour fast
right now
really yeah just doing it to test myself
there's a challenge you actually eat the
Sun yeah sunlight yes that's real yeah I
think I did a 17-day fast but I didn't
know food yeah that's good no juice
that's great I'll do that too sometimes
yeah well one there's also breatharians
never heard of breatharian people will
just breathe yeah that's uh they don't
they drink a very small amount of water
but they all live off their breath but
if you watch these people talk they have
a hard time putting a sentence together
which is interesting to me I kind of
look one of these guys yeah that's some
ho-ass out right now i did the video
with the most complicated [ __ ] oh I just
blew your mind with that
you're gonna start just breathing bro
I'm thinking about I gotta go that route
and some kind of capacity and see or do
this people do I'm afraid
yeah I can you know it yeah yeah eating
the Sun is enough well these people do
it and then I don't buy it because
they're not doing that well
they're [ __ ] they're like they can
barely breathe through talking it just
doesn't make sense to me so what do you
eat these days me what I yeah I use the
[ __ ] I want to eat okay I don't touch
pork I don't touch beef we don't [ __ ]
with no chicken we just like
pescetarians but then it get to a point
where workout gout kick in we eat a lot
of seafood so from Easter so for me did
I am what I have fun in was not vegan
but I just I never ate nothing with a
heart hmm so you know if you don't have
a heart I won't eat it
mmm I think I feel more comfortable my
life I tried everywhere and yeah I felt
more comfortable like that I believe
that the possibility for what person to
live without consuming food and in some
cases water ooh
breath to Terry and claim that food is
not necessary for survival and a man can
obtain slowly by what piranha prana and
vital life and Hindu with them yeah try
it out do that Mike you could do 30 days
in it I don't know well food get so
dogmatic listen them we have to come to
the room Sammy when we look at the life
and we say who are we worried from what
is our purpose here right in them you
think of it for my little insight 150
years 53 years whatever it is and when
you're going to say you want to go
towards the step of enlightenment and
from my insider Sonia in the
enlightenment world life is the
willingness to
you know and then like human world
that's what life is the willingness to
die the free yourself from everything
that you're that you're afraid of the
only way we only wanna live for long
time because we're afraid that's what
we're afraid we don't even know why when
everyone little bit afraid to die but we
know all about all of our journeys all
of our searches that we search since the
beginning of time ever in our heritage
with our family our ancestors probably
felt once we no longer exist but we want
to know we want to know knowledge
without going to the afterlife and to
get it that's all we search for his
knowledge by active purpose yes all he
do you know rap songs and I my thinking
we think we're attached to God to the to
the mighty being we think we know his
plan with us from my perspective of our
ego sometimes we think this is just our
world everything else is an illusion
[Music]
yeah and he can't play with Mike exalt
rue des facts yeah that's one that's
some real [ __ ] yeah somebody told me
like a walk if you living that's life I
said heís living high highs living your
life it's crazy we might say cuz for me
I accepted death Jamia if hell worse
than this than hey hey a [ __ ] no evil
she should be a meal no cuz I'm I'm
under the belief for my my [ __ ] my
fourth grade [ __ ] educated but from
what mine incitement of what my life is
about yeah you think I'm life begins
once we die yeah can you imagine that
existence I'm gonna think but sometimes
I think about that poom and I think wow
[ __ ] eggs it's not existing with now
your voice don't mean [ __ ] now we could
talk [ __ ] Michael's gonna be tough guys
we could be humble we can give any kind
of imagine we not have you don't have
that manually come to the point that we
feel Envy that there were nothing
the ego with allied life is meaningless
and when it'll definitely never double
yeah I feel like it yeah we all have
these great agendas that we're gonna
meet God how can we never say we're
gonna meet the devil how come with who
do we think we're worthy of meeting God
all the secrets that we got that we did
that no one knows what you makes it
makes you think we worthy of meeting God
with all our secrets and [ __ ] what
secrets of God I don't know but we think
that secret but we won't tell everybody
i secrets movie not all the physical oh
no III can't lie humbly see right here
sir I ain't got none no no no that's a
beautiful way to know anything I'll go
be right here hold different so tell me
what are you doing now yeah brother you
look great Oh ma'am living yeah I'm
taking his word I'll call no I'll call
it I used to be nice to be real for me
it being an artist I felt like I felt
illiterate because I didn't have to be
smart no more hmm
I have to learn nothing else no mo I
ain't even have to be humble all I had
to do was rap make this [ __ ] look good
and get rich and no district to anybody
for me I I felt I felt I was watching
Wizard of Oz and I'm like down I'm like
the [ __ ] 10 minute no brain no heart
just somebody getting paid being famous
for it
so that's what I start getting into the
motive waka flocka flame is Walmart
that's Toys R Us it's targeted Sears
it became my alter ego you know I'm
saying I forgot who I was I never knew
how I feel to be 21 years old being what
they say normal yeah so I had to take
off like time with my rap career like
thang thang this Waka Flocka hey thank
you what you did for me but salida [ __ ]
I hate what you did that I take it got
out of hand
so I started learning how to beat Walker
that's why I start doing like idioms and
funny as Peter she did she cuz that's
what Walker wanna do
that in a date slum like hey what's
gangster night like hey what is gangster
like to thank I had to free to leaking
me in my face I got no well I got them
playing dancing with my dog I'm like
yeah so I'll start contradicting myself
oh when I got to that point I saw
gliding now what am i doing if I do look
high what's why is the word are are why
is the word seven seven you know since
the odd number you take a say s office
even [ __ ] like that be playing with your
mind how can you use certain words three
times but it it's the same work with me
both different things and I got to that
point oh you know some [ __ ] I'm still
hoping their businesses [ __ ] that I'm
get on YouTube I started learning how to
do QuickBooks off you to pan I start
learning it quick easy [ __ ] so I caught
up to now that start doing stocks these
[ __ ] bitcoins [ __ ] with people
that do coded I did everything under the
Sun because music I got so much money
off music but I was dumb as [ __ ] I was
like I got my never broke [ __ ] swag of
a racing that was my mother it was real
[ __ ] baby might like what's so big homie
I might be hungry [ __ ] also got that
out of like a big dog I want you to
invest in this I couldn't see past that
[ __ ] I couldn't see past all right [ __ ]
what you lose yourself who do you
believe you are who do I believe I am
yeah I am Who I am Who I am
I mean I am whoever you think I need to
find yourself can i define myself
that'd be arrogant I rather people for
it only you could do people can't define
you I get people to find you honestly
ain't finish it I can't you can't define
you know I ain't doing my I ain't even
nowhere near done I just opened up my
first file company's ain't done yet how
old do you brother
I'm 33 33 yes I'm 32 so yeah if you have
a daughter listen I want to play a nine
game right quick yeah I got a fortune
you I'm gonna play a nine game oh that's
annoying you huh like every number in
we're not okay
I believe it I've got will go back to my
daughter I know how did I do this
is seven-year-old I have 14 you well
yeah so how can i rap like what am I
talking about I'm 33
how can I write with somebody 18 I
should be teaching them not arriving
with them hmm
I'm saying it's time you got to move
over like how much money I think to
myself like they got 20 million oh I got
started right now
Oh nobody nothing like what am i doing
yeah like what the [ __ ] am i why do I
need to put a note Seija to make you say
on fine to make it another 20 now I'm
gonna use up I can use five hundred
thousand on the startup and sell that
[ __ ] at 6 million they keep doing it
over and over and over and over over
mmm walking run my credit up get along
buy a house get a 90/10 deal get a table
I wanna start paying Ishi's back and
make that keep turning
when I found out I could keep making
money legally I'm like okay I got ya I
got a trucking company a staffing
company a medical transportation company
mmm counter tech companies I might be
bringing to Atlanta probably I know is
gonna be one of the biggest companies
ever hit Georgia but it's a lot of [ __ ]
gets interesting you said it and so
we're going to another placement so I
said it to myself that so what the [ __ ]
am i doing how do I get this podcast you
know I don't think podcasting [ __ ] then
I go on then he shows me some Dennis
show me some [ __ ] all these
[ __ ] think I'm some guru and
[ __ ] so this is yeah listen man you
gotta see how much pull I got on this
thing and I'm are this is crazy and
that's why I listen I know I'm not
conscious of it like that mr. Lee
talking [ __ ] she'd I really don't even
know what I'm talking about but the
perspective is that I just know what I'm
talking well so I'm I got I got I got to
tell the people out there who think I
know what I'm talking about in some kind
of way really I don't know what I'm
talking about but it's still cool in
there either what yeah but does anybody
know what they're talking I think you
know we don't know I really don't know
how old I am do you see this at 265 days
so he know before they said that it's
only 28 days 13 well that too so I don't
how many fingers you got my
I don't know five ten how many things
you go to ten yeah you got nine but they
start with zero number one but they
taught us backwards how do you know such
as there are I will go with an R they
may come a little one I have nine hands
then that's interesting
what does that mean no my what does I
mean what is my purpose
you know like you don't tell you my new
my funny lobby Ben yeah yo bro
I heard the such thing called mathletes
oh yeah not a fleet yeah I told myself
by 2021 I'ma be a Matthew I had this
love that bro how's it going um you know
it's some [ __ ] no AC I'm gonna get it
wrong I know he's good huh wait but what
does that mean if it starts at zero yeah
alright the fast you ever heard the
human calculator never y'all gonna enjoy
him Heaney come on the show human
calculator enjoy watching it he's the
human calculator out be calculated he
got out he got out do anybody studying
in for a solid five months right now
yeah about 20 21 I'll be a hole watch I
build these [ __ ] screaming
honest well do you know this thing
there's this principle in quantum
physics that a thing doesn't exist until
you go to measure it and then it exists
like on a molecular level the atomic
brother no I think this when I faded
this exactly exactly exactly so when you
take that out that model out and you
apply it to everything we do in life
it's like how does anybody know anything
everything that people talk about are
just theories and I don't know anything
that's what we made of Adam and Eve and
made up all these great prophets and
made up you know these scenarios in life
mmm
and fanfare Maga it's part of my whole
life for 70 years all I did was [ __ ]
[ __ ] and drink and party Europe and
say I'm the guy that study life for 70
years and after in there 70 years
meaning this guy both know [ __ ] about
the world right and I studied the world
for seven years any party for 70 years
and the day we're both even in our
knowledge of the world in different
[ __ ] I think I know more than him
cuz I know some because I know some ten
to ten and five and all that [ __ ] so I
think I'm smarter than him but the end
of the day I can't say Who I am okay I'm
coming what's my purpose here neither
can he and what's this fella but I can I
can reenact who created God how did God
come into existence well the day
everybody thought were spinning but
those questions don't even really matter
in the grand scheme of our existence
when did God come into being doesn't
really help me in my life
I helped me my life cuz I want to be I
want to be connected to that source of
being I'm connected to it though but it
can be ancient I know I just want to
know I want to know your thumb it's all
gentle words oh yeah Mike so I've been
on this origin train finding my own my
own origin I've traced it back to my
first American ancestor in the 1600s she
came here from England her name was Mary
bliss parson she was on trial for
witchcraft three times man may found Mac
name with two Mayflower people yes she
came and settled this town in
Massachusetts her and her husband check
this out centuries later we're working
on this new podcast about this guy Jack
Parsons he's the father of modern
rocketry founded JPL he's also he was
deep into magic and rituals and he'd do
these sex magic rituals because he
believed at the time of orgasm with the
right intention you could manifest
anything you wanted into reality and he
did all of these ceremonies and he's
crazy ritual
to manifest spirits to help help him
build a rocket to get man to the moon I
start researching this guy it turns out
he's like my [ __ ] cousin talking
about origins and reincarnation and you
know our souls purpose here you know we
have a we have a reason to be here I
don't know exactly just as the ants have
a reason to be here
yeah something listen and no people I'm
talking about the animals to have
something to do it ie though I equals
involved with in some kind of capacity
well what is the ego in nature to willed
the will to improve yourself oh god yeah
flock what do you think no I know you're
on this level dude let us start what do
you think about the well you talked a
lot about it and I really I've ibed with
what you said cuz I played in the NFL
and I came out of the NFL in my late 20s
going what the [ __ ] do I have to show
for my whole life you know I had this
dream of reach making this goal of
achieving this thing I did it I was
successful and then it didn't bring me
everything I thought it would you know
and then I looked back and I was like
man I never got to be a kid I was never
had the experience of a normal 21 year
old you know and now I have a 7 year old
daughter and all of this you know grown
man life responsibilities that I wasn't
equipped for at all
you know people when I went I was just a
straight line man from high school to
college into the NFL and people were
taking care of [ __ ] all along the way
and I didn't have to learn a [ __ ]
thing about how to function in a regular
society
you know I was a warrior on the warpath
to achieve this thing and I did it and
you know for the most part outside of
football life was about keeping that
adrenaline rush going women drugs
[ __ ] alcohol whatever it possibly was
you know and I came out of it totally
devastated yeah you know and I had no
idea who I was or what I was supposed to
do with my life and slowly but surely I
got in touch with the [ __ ] that is at
the center of my core essence of Who I
am my spirit in this world the [ __ ] that
looks out of this body which is [ __ ]
weird right to be a consciousness
looking out of this vehicle you know
because we've [ __ ] we've been so
disillusioned with life you know we've
become it's all about making money and
materiality and achieving this sort of
superficial success that once we achieve
that we realize oh [ __ ] that wasn't the
answer you know but then you start to do
all these other things man like you have
all these businesses it's incredible to
hear you talk about you know your vision
for your life and who you are and you
know you dissected that really quickly
yeah and what was that about you know
your transition as a musician and an
artist into being an entrepreneur you
know was it was there a moment idealism
benefit that you know you threw out yeah
and I can get him to yo you know what I
mean I always was just a go with the
flow
I mean I just went with the flow like
[ __ ] I ain't yeah you know rap I just
did it yeah I would wrap it so [ __ ] hey
let me go with the flow mmm now when I
feel like I got a feeling I see my good
I'll I just want good on listen to my
brain
yeah almost to my car's on the net
how's it straight to my gut so my gut
tell me like y'all get sorry it's the
right feeling for me I did it for music
I just I felt like [ __ ] if I make a
couple of good records I fire sound like
a last 20 years
hmm like what make the Beatles listen to
one record yeah she don't say like I
tried the record came out 11 years ago
she sound like he dropped yesterday mmm
hey that's [ __ ] better than making a
hundred records yeah classics I bought
some to the game that was different like
out nobody her kicks an 808 ever to walk
a [ __ ] cool I thought I could live
with it I start wanting credit and
wanted more credit cards yeah
something I started I just started I
just thought I want to be funny I can't
wait to be 40 years old no I mean I got
seven years to get there I can't wait
like I'm not that kind of person want to
live yeah like I can't do it Yeah right
nobody oh you know when you young you
dumb I'm saying yeah yeah no doubt you
don't know though you don't know why not
I blew it buddy that's a lot of a tsetse
fly lifted oh my god I burned through a
lot of money dude it's just like now
master I want what I want is financial
literacy yeah I think I feel that I got
financial literacy I know my purpose my
purpose is to get well I'm a universal
man I believe in the universe I love it
the universe is beautiful light job Hey
nothing is better than Universal if I
want answers I fast and go straight to
do to select trees and [ __ ] around like
nature I swear to God and just know it
whoever know we know me they know that
I'm one I get there my heart I know they
love that dude no higher slogan I fire
fast move
that's very interesting like what do you
think well I think this is understanding
the pretty cool to tell me about some of
tell me about in New York stories New
York stories yeah
born in Queens on me in New York before
yeah you know me
yeah no bit me and my mom he used to go
out with Carol many years ago with Carol
by Bobby's sister yeah you used to used
to be friends with your limos limos and
[ __ ] yes Mike right there yeah it was
face and you know so I grew up like me
growing Roxy Run DMC boys they all from
up there literally like I literally they
also yeah she see any folks he's like I
never said this is my crib same woman
like his cat but it's just not even
captured slam I ain't for me looking
back as a kid that [ __ ] was so normal to
be seeing superstar over stars like I
grew up in the hood but it was rich it
was like hood rich people with class
respect like it wasn't this wow like you
could talk to your mama Wow like no the
[ __ ] I ain't grow up with cameras and a
my scene is bad like it just me knowing
that I can't talk about nobody nice the
judge focusing that's what I didn't know
myself and I go back to this once I
started trusting myself everything stop
falling in line like people could do
[ __ ] now and I got this one thing if I
was to have religion to sound soft as
love to me she you actually if you acts
love you'll be like I'm gonna push me
will love this man let it go smaller
block in a ruining world that's lame I
think it's two different definitions of
real be real [ __ ] to me now I'm 53 so
the real [ __ ] to me if the Prince he
knows everything he knows with he know
what situation is gonna get him in this
situation he's been in that situation
before yeah so he understands if he
reacts this way what's gonna happen
what's through them this is how he's
gonna respond
yes is the real [ __ ] the guy that walks
away and just you know he walks away
from me gotta disrespect them and call
them sumbitches and stuff and there's
some way that my mind look bad look
falls upon that guy yeah you know yeah
those are the real [ __ ]
doctor oh yeah well 20 $20 I'm trying to
I'm gonna excuse me I'm gonna replace
where a [ __ ] with King but I have to
like I just have it's a contradiction
like for me personally like I told
myself I'm making my so my music I said
his last evening it's around like I like
for me to judge somebody like I got to
change my way to think I have to and he
got to start with eating in the words
you choose in the movies you watch
actually so deep like for me people my
wife hey cuz I only watch scary movies I
used towards me like data what forensic
father and what sitting there all he was
telling what's in them yeah you know who
you are when you get conscious you kind
of figure out who you are it's like why
be gangsters oh man so many friends
trying to be tough and they were tough
but being tough is then worth losing
their vice you know yeah that's my flow
Mike if I did anything wrong my career I
couldn't save the lives that I want to
say cuz I was immature and if I had the
mind I got right now I promise to you my
little brother wouldn't committed
suicide I put down on my shoulders my
best friend to be alive my other best
friend oh I know there'll be alive well
my mind said right now I know for a fact
I know it right now we'll be up to
hundred properties from 50 commercial
businesses I know right now my mind said
that 16 yeah I said that when I started
making that would to help my friends out
there was always being locked up and
Sons I thought if I broke them off and
gave them money that they wouldn't do it
no more they became worse it became more
tyrannical
you know that's their destiny God will
God has everything written or the
universal
because everything written you know
that's true you do not be amplified huh
it's different like something something
must not cut y'all some people like them
why can't keep it real no more I had to
break it down to myself I'm like down
every time I see you don't give me like
a thousand dollar file I swear
one year my accountant counted up right
70 or 60 percent went to give the money
up well that's not keeping it real
giving money I know I still feel I might
have dumb I'm not even don't all right
you know but go back to being a real
[ __ ] yo you live as hell and have
[ __ ] pepper you not now but but
definitely but that's what that's what
this new position created like yo yeah
honesty crazies your enemy well listen
um technically you want you to do some
money how much money you need how much
money they asked you for this is random
you know somebody do man needs any 500
5000 [ __ ] well that's good too all
right I said it's not you at your annual
sometime next week or sometime right oh
right now clean my car go to the store
for me give me some candy they keep my
mother still oh I can't do that
oh no why not you know what how could
you do that like you did that night
first but yeah that's what I do
oh you know what you have to they never
respect you after you're in the respect
nor this it's actually a universal law
it's a universal law unless in my bar
some that you know can't pay back in
charge interest my yeah I believe that
oh so that's interest that's not me
doing that doesn't mean having them if
you work for me and take this man go to
store he might get his things a job I
found out was cheaper to put people on
salary now I'm giving my but at the end
of the day if somebody with no ambition
I'll create a lazy human being and then
if you stop feeding that lazy you be
there blame you and technically you
crippled
oh no that happened to me i crippled a
lot of time sometimes I beat these lazy
individuals I kicked them get the [ __ ]
out of here you destroying our industry
your purpose is to improve it you have
to put something into this industry you
have to make your job to make this a
better industry and if you can't make it
better you're only making it worse
so you gotta go well you know it's all
perception you know this perception but
for your perception of people in your
world and I'm no purpose in your world
what the [ __ ] are they doing in your
world box oh I've got it for now it's
like hit my I'm like they get we talk
bad day right now it's like yeah so many
girlfriends no why should I know about
you in the money they would give me puts
out with you're such a sex addict
that was my [ __ ] goal I was just a
dick that's me actually a dick or you
like dipping the stick I was just a pic
where you got where you got guilty like
you may have you may have [ __ ] money
you know you really shouldn't the [ __ ]
that's your friend friend's wife or your
ex-wife oh [ __ ] whoo and yes it's normal
but it's not normal you know I mean the
act is normal but the concept of it is
bad that's what I have my guilt for my
dick of a big part of my guilt of my
life yeah yeah I feel that my guilt is
not saving man I was talking did you
save you know I can't even love myself -
who the [ __ ] do I think I am I'm capable
of saving some money I can't save myself
why can't I save myself right now for
this since nothing stuffed I'm saying
now what can I think my cellphone is I
had a lot of money before and I know I'm
I was that was thought when I was at the
lowest point of my life I thought I
didn't [ __ ] I'm from my family we
lived in can then build why do I have
money that's just what do they do play a
big party a little [ __ ] do I got a
hundred million now as I'm what 21 years
or whatever what am i doing I'm in the
[ __ ] fancy hotel I'm eating cabbie I
mean all this [ __ ] I hear with the flash
see I got a bunch of naked people in my
room and I said this is what life is
about this is with all the big-time guys
that I looked up to told me but this is
what they did so this is what it is I
had no concept of who I was nothing this
is what life is about killing yourself
dying to live it's bad yes fast you
definitely done I live I felt like that
I woke up popping I see part two two
pills before five o'clock experience I'd
at least be on at least three pills a
day faithfully faithfully from 2013 all
the way up to fight 2012 2003 2004 2005
ish I say all waited to thousands were
beans yeah that's that stuff burns and
listen I know I'm I took some ecstasy
that's the e thing your brain it
deteriorates your brain and stuff yeah
you did a number on me too I guess it's
not making me use my whole brain thank
God I did a lot of cocaine that made me
hallucinate like it's a seizure that
wasn't actually there
[Music]
that's intent
what did ecstasy do for you
it made me sweater I just make you read
just trying to escape
definitely pain I had a lot of pain
you're in a lot of talent I see made you
feel cousin my little brother had opened
up boo brains on for no I'm saying like
just seeing shootouts and just like your
daddy dying in the hospital random [ __ ]
it [ __ ] was you as a kid yeah being
unsuccessful being told you this society
I may be who we are watching your mother
struggle that doesn't make us who we
have on a month it made me not complain
I couldn't blame nobody like I got a
beauty story at I'm like my little
brother got your hair ran over by a
drunk driver
that was my next-door neighbor in the
white man and he served no jail time
did they make me hate all life oh no it
just let me know how the society is if
you rich will connect
she could happen you see what I'm saying
like I watched homeboys trade on each
other
I was business partners slime each other
behind
like this is the life I seen I went to a
church what pastor but to my wife
oh that's me growing up that's it the
world I'm sorry life is I've been
waiting they would bomb just telling you
as a kid I watched two friends and
behind one back this guy selling that
[ __ ] mama Cray I watched him go whines
back and sleep with his sister like I
seen so much treachery that to the point
where it made me not be like oh [ __ ]
that's what I'm not gonna be she don't
be this so for me people who say you
could be a product the environment that
is true but my mother when you when you
got parents or parent or family members
that is building yo yo mind long as they
build to build a strong mind and make
you classy I promise you can't [ __ ]
break you easy that's the problem people
even put confidence in any kids like I
thank God my mom put confidence in me
cuz I don't know what happy watching her
accomplish everything it made me too
strong I'm telling you I just want I
want the brain to the table what a man
do cuz I watched my mama D I might [ __ ]
I might show you what a man do cuz I
ain't see a man my life so it just built
a different kind of alimony you see I'm
saying so I live one thing about people
if you don't know me
[ __ ] your opinion I never I'll never
understand people that get on Instagram
and argue people they don't know right
no you don't know me I don't give a [ __ ]
then if you know me should have come
right to my face right like I'm just
ma'am tonight trying to be hard and then
I know I know my purpose I know it I'm
leaving to do it and the day I feel like
talking about it is it but why should
people like Mike when I was I was a
young [ __ ] I'm sure I can say my phone
call my spank me my brother sin a pilot
I'm telling I say Mike is the best
person ever in the world to get me oh
dipping that [ __ ] running right into you
Johnny like in your ass boys but that's
how it is you see what I'm saying like
ah I know I grew up watching Mike yeah
yeah
mark my conscience was just different
you know
I got seeing so much excellence like
this should the world today just I don't
know man
no distract the kids and the youth faces
they get the young too much credit yeah
they don't let the young live yeah all
days they let us live it was not about
being a young successful bounce back in
your thirties yeah it was cool to be a
yo 30 yeah yeah like my daughter
everybody what your daughter doing what
she gonna be X you 14 yeah yeah whatever
you want to be if you want to work at
Kroger I'm a support machine working out
she were my body mom you know we look at
the aspect that you know time is moving
you know only purpose is were born to
die and every tenth of the [ __ ] way
if that closer toward death when we see
the gray night here that's not as
getting older that's death there's a
concept of dying well possibly wise so
many old mother can't get great here
that's good that's a watch you can get
gray here Wow you know walking be didn't
live long enough to hear whatever
what if we're here what if our purpose
is to evolve man how do we involve to
what degree our consciousness everything
that we're talking about in here
aspiring constantly aspiring far be
better yesterday Cosmo well maybe we're
just were just grown sperm even look at
this consciousness evolving like a thumb
you think about the reach up mean ll
were talking about regions in our
highest potential yeah when you think
you reach your highest retention when
you know long exist yeah yeah you know
probably when you know you reach eyes we
tend to think it's a good
in an email um you can go no longer and
to take it the next step all of your
consciousness all of the work that
you've all the energy you put into the
universe is now trickles down into the
next generation exactly and it builds
their consciousness nobody no - neighs -
yeah I'll count me books you read mm-hmm
I don't care what the folks tell me
somebody tell me eight I worship God my
how the universe humbled us you know we
don't know anything I'm always learning
every day every day I'm waking the winds
here today I wake up seven and one
eighteen one air day I can only sleep at
45 minutes be straight I think we're
just we do we just like fruit food the
[ __ ] fruit we have a season where we
we no longer exist you know we get ripe
fruit that's what made me uh going back
to the vegan question
that's what made me realize that man was
never supposed to eat meat because in
the Bible to meet was the husk of a
fruit that's they called me really the
fruit was the meat no free but that's
like people saying money is even what
for the love of money but that's a whole
there's a whole nother vibe listen what
do you think you think we little more
God conscious now do me worth or damn
10,000 years ago I don't know I don't
think so no nothing you know everything
was gone yeah everything was worshipping
Chris all day yeah Welsh Guards been
almost squeezed out him for God building
billion for God's gonna be like I'm ten
thousand years ago everything was about
building even more with our building for
God building for
building the biggest buildings in the
world yeah to reach God they'll call him
something else
yeah many things it's like else
something else you know you know but it
wasn't even God God is a if you're what
you call yourself
african-american God is technically a
European word I think I know it is I'm
telling you this uh for me I'm on
digitus it's a big difference like yes
if we talk in essence do y'all believe
in slavery that all the slaves came from
overseas in South America
meaning what I believe in said yeah I do
believe in slavery there was same thing
I was yeah like all of them fitting on
their boat and came in no you think on
durations probably 400 this day 200 this
day of whatever that day so to speak
yeah I wasn't humanly possible they was
already here that wasn't that was
impossible it's already here well I've
read some books on some slaves with
narratives and they said they were in
the boat you know however they said you
know words of the slaves my folks some
people some people don't believe that
the world is round they think it's flat
you believe the war around I don't know
what I believe you believe it's flat you
do yeah okay I'm gonna break it down ya
know I don't know what to believe them
stop [ __ ] you believe in the universe
definitely laws of the university - yeah
why do we always look up why don't we
look down why don't we look in the ocean
because there's more company [ __ ]
with that ocean you're on your own baby
ain't getting on a boat I'm a man hell
no you can't tell me who's in that water
nobody in his room knows in that water
yeah we know less about the ocean than
we do
yeah so they say that's true that's a
month that's true among older they can't
feed after you the tentacle to feel they
have no eyes to talk down that no
sunlight they got a lake in Georgia that
people just mysteriously always die
disappear not as real [ __ ] like my
friends was a lifeguard jumped in that
water and disappeared
what so you know someone I don't play
with no water man look it up Wow
what's the lake called egg the Georgia
Hani Hani Lake just go to take that in
haunted Georgia when the next rap show
you going to leave your next concert
pretty nice yeah yeah Lake Lanier linear
so I just like built over the entire
town oh it's we all saw my birthday made
30,000 ected bro it's all connected
controversy over the last few weeks
after a series of tragic incidents
claimed alive with multiple drowning
victim over over Memorial Day weekend
drowning in 30 year old Regina's Terrell
Whitehead went under the water and never
never resurfaced after falling off of
his jet ski 24 hours prior to the
whiteheads 61 year old Michael Thompson
of Gainesville drowned near a boat boat
dock near Lake land
just weeks before April 28th
seventeen-year-old Dante Maine of
Lithuania was pulled away from the water
after nearly drowning a.m. latest
reports list him in critical conditions
Wow whoa okay so what's the Dare the
lake is on it as a result of the
multiple incidents reported residents
and visitors alike have changed that the
lake is on it
holy moly the Dove love signs they built
they built the lake over a whole city a
drought the city oh yeah what's up we
got waka flocka man I bid Achtung flames
flames in the air you don't you got two
phones bro what do you do with the two
phone what do you think about technology
man I think it's zapping or hilarity no
doubt about it yeah nah you know what it
is man some people call this the death
of humanity to me I'll call this [ __ ] a
bicycle okay this is a bicycle yeah see
the right way to look at yeah I approach
it yeah
it's different yeah anybody else now
that's it's a bicycle
what you doing a bus boom you know when
I'm talking about that we're talking
about right now that thing disappears
right now how will you react and [ __ ] it
so I can't wait and we fail to go in my
phone I need my phone they can't stand
star load
it's crazy hey I do mind the way tell us
about this thing going down with
America's Got Talent
you on that now what are you talking
about
they fired somebody and you're talking
about a boycott run tests show that [ __ ]
was on TMZ this fourth advertisement man
now how they can reduce you like that
you're not calling for a boycott Waka
Flocka call for boycott put me in a
blender look you say Gabrielle Union AGT
firing races damn see the headline when
I headlined me more than the actual
video that's the area I live in I'm
sorry I know I'm sorry dude we're living
in a society that still think race is a
joke that's kind of what I'm after
terrible question we live in that
society I think you live in a society
where the people that was racist in
today last straw they owe this [ __ ] you
know I'm saying so anybody under the age
of the [ __ ] forty years old and
that's racist ain't got a house of ill
talk to them literally talk yeah you
know I mean so you so anybody acting
racist or even taking these traditions
that come from racism that's a taught
thing to it when you find out and you
still want to carry along tradition
that's [ __ ] up so like say for
instance they told her she could get
together memos about her hair about
changing her clothes stuff like that
like does that come with black culture
or like is that a part of us they won't
you change who you are that's up to you
to change it's not to you to the plane
don't change can you move it
expose it keep it moving
if you want change you got to buy boots
that's how I go that's it
so how do we move forward for my stuff
like this how do we do how do we how do
we take teachable moments like say
people like Gabrielle Union like me
putting up a front just putting it out
there not trying to be credit before I'm
not trying to stand on the news for it
did they her job to someone they turn
that into this [ __ ] headline anybody
it should be black people should boycott
look at this but I think adding on you
say black do I say indigenous indigenous
that's crazy dude what do you think
about I mean lows hey before Columbus
that's why I say indigenous Native
Americans or you're saying African
people were in America before Columbus
what are you from what you call yourself
your European American by just yeah yes
so do you tie to yourself is that no so
a lot of [ __ ] see you tired of self
african-american I'm a Mexican and I'm
an Indian American like [ __ ]
[ __ ] not even nothing it's a color and
the colors don't exist so it's like it's
me who's here before Columbus and we
lost I'm red tail Blackfoot Indian was
powered being [ __ ] well there you go
yeah he want to be a [ __ ] I think I'm
probably an alien probably descended
from someone who came from another
planet I would like this I need more of
that I would think if I would think of
Lucy the latest oldest person in the
world when four million I always think
like this where is my bloodline at that
time when Lucy was involved ya know who
was my brother who was it at the time
was I involved with Lucy around Europe
somewhat I need you some where's my
I'm 4.4 million years ago yeah oh did it
exist at that time yeah go to
ancestry.com and trace your paperwork
all way back my paperwork is [ __ ]
my parents are pimps and prostitutes we
don't got a paper [ __ ] you could
change that last night no I chased my
listen this is not even my father's last
name my mother took the lesson and she
married Tyson but that wasn't my father
my mother cheated untighten a date Wow
when can he go there yeah he's one of
those people
hmm some person she's one of the persons
if you were her kid she was great tea
but anything outside of that you then
give a [ __ ] about you know long slow
dumb kids that's important but you can
never know this is what I found that was
discussing this with myself yeah I was
thinking about my relationship with my
mother and you know sometimes I think
about my mother and I say to myself how
do you how do you get the love that your
mother gives you from your wife how did
you get that love taking love doesn't
exist with a man and a woman and
sometimes I think I've been looking for
that love for my mother and my woman and
it doesn't exist and that's why I've
been disasterous yeah
and now you started thinking about that
yeah I can't even I can't even explain
it to find the love but I'm trying to
put a bit I can't explain it the love I
can't explain yeah I can't explain it
you know it's just that deep love you
weren't here was just to go through
anything for you anything and just even
if she was mad at you did something bad
that she walked through the wall walk
through the train for you yes would do
anything for you even though you're
wrong I'm gonna listen this is what I
came to a conclusion
your mother's your slave in a way so you
wanna
you want some what you want a slave that
protects you that's what you look for in
your wife somebody's gonna do whatever
you say
and anyway you won't even know your
physical terms you're supposed to be a
protector but you need to protect you in
life yeah for the pitfalls in life and
that's why I think we find makes a
mistake when we look for a mother I want
my wife in a yeah yeah yeah we're never
gonna get down [ __ ] no yeah and i'ii go
tell you we can't go with fire we got
money with max when they look at you
can't pay for that my woman I tell you
my god yo yo my woman boy she'll run in
front of the bus running foot of the car
jump in front of that bully but I never
forced her to getting that put in that
spot but I know she I know she with me
for for infinity I'm telling I found it
like my mom telling you my keys out here
man
you got open up your heart be dog you
wanna did you got a ring on your finger
yeah but I miss thing it's just not like
that yeah I think it's you have to end
sometimes sometimes sometimes you have
to look in the work know about it
we need to know the history of black
women you know the history of black
women then you understand your
relationship with though if you're a
black man I love what's the one that's
here the history a black woman cuz then
we know this is what we love you know
what's this noise I love no no we should
comfort to love my concept love is
undeniable Phil what's that undeniable
as long as a sacrifice whether the two
you know it's just I I never feel
nothing that could compared to help
really I don't even have a definition
for it I only think it's nothing a word
I could compare with it and yet
definitely with love right yeah I don't
know I don't let love consume me like
that Mikey use I'm not even consumed I'm
just telling you like it's a feeling
that just it's not about highs like it's
in his own category it's like it's
little it's love day what I'm saying
some people mistreat the worried and
abused and they actually take it to only
know maybe if they're five billion
people and maybe they're five different
five billion definition right tell you I
know that's like it's like xining like
it's a smile
it's the reason I don't know loveth to
be challenged what is this purpose I
know that I was talking to my wife lives
there for you baby you know I'm like
laughing it's involuntary you can laugh
when it's know when you're not even when
there's nothing funny you know it's a
it's an involuntary motion something
that has to be funny he has to chill out
what's my form both of this was me you
know that laughing is just not something
that we plan ya know it's looking to the
concept of our feelings and the thought
of him in you know I mean I thought we
are human animals during that book is
just I just bought their book the hard
of hearing
yeah and I bought it another bookstore
everyone it's all red and blue book this
understand people like Peter Green I
think about the book right
are of human was in human nature on
everything inc °o° gonna check that out
blow over it where do you live
Georgia Atlanta Georgia
sweet huh I love it I ain't movin
yeah you remember being in your
neighborhood going outside everybody
know everybody dance it now there's
nothing like la you don't gotta go to no
one but it's a big-ass neighborhood and
listen right
in fact cool guy like me right like you
say you look like imagine a guy like me
in a city like that without my wife I'm
gonna see my friend with a bunch of
black women I can't even I can't listen
I can't even talking to room with a
bunch of beautiful black women I sit in
the corner like a [ __ ] geek so what
the [ __ ] my girl be living in Atlanta
for I can't live with a bunch of black
people man my mind [ __ ] my basic
humanistic start coming out I don't
bring their podcast down we have no that
[ __ ] beautiful and [ __ ] Erica my
[ __ ] beautiful
oh it's amazing fire guys stay away from
the food oh yeah you're definitely y'all
definitely go games away you get full 24
hours out club down in the six in the
morning area then walk through just some
beautiful people out there hotel really
beautiful people here from different
parts of the world a country Mississippi
beautiful interesting is that
interesting literally yeah
and you are all here so fashion for
Atlanta everything fashion but it's kind
of like man [ __ ]
I mean it's the comfortable yes
comfortable you gotta you gotta know
yeah but at the end of the day you gotta
be who you are
yeah cuz once again it's a big-ass
neighborhood yeah yeah la is filled with
people who are just expressing
themselves you know I like it - I like
it - you mean it can't be that way
it's dope I moved back here now I [ __ ]
what I love Billy oh yeah
I love everywhere but ain't no way I
like jobs yeah no well yeah this or any
other place I hate man ain't nowhere
like it
1976 like was the first time I went to
UM 42nd Street
uh-huh I was 10 years old I went up
there and um the older guys named bubs
he went up there and the purpose that we
want to do was to go in people's pockets
and take their money and some time we
were going train coming back and the
train coming back from Manhattan took
whatever they had to go to lower
Manhattan to like Tennessee when they
come before Second Coming always
downtown we were going and beep
acquiesce Rams that take rip everything
like savage it's like like the army like
you know King is Kong coming you just
ribbit the pistol-packing we just
rapping the coast and they got minks
ripping everything the Rings it's like a
smorgasbord of barbarians 30 of us and
as you notice pecking me is crabbing
it's just like it's crazy that's the
world I come from like you say so I'm
laughing Wow
yeah you know why because the I was part
of my environment if I didn't do the
listen if I wasn't like that then I'm a
victim and that whole logic yeah I see
the Hmong genius [ __ ] you actually broke
the chains because now you would never
family have kids know that you know that
money nothing else exists you did you
did you do oh absolutely my kids what
once as a person that you get to
point money it's like you know
everything else I do is a plus why don't
[ __ ] my accent I'm a little full
mm-hmm
yeah I'm like a Magic Mike he got a he
he got anybody's family closer close to
him boxing guess what he could tell him
what to do now
yeah that's a chain breaker it's nothing
like everything else is would you tell
my partner that was your presence to be
a better you you just we have a better
you neck her instantly yeah like a
family kid that the Harvard Stanford
it's empty I didn't listen
I finished the eighth or ninth grade but
it was really bad was like the [ __ ]
eighth me the [ __ ] Special Olympics
cool [ __ ] you know specially you know
but it wasn't that was stupid but I saw
with Rob the teachers Robbie yeah client
from this guy he's robbing me he comes
to school the next day then I come to
school the next day looking at me what
the [ __ ] one minute she calling the
police took my wallet back in class the
next day my mother made me come to
school she was standing out there so
she's coming upstairs as you wait did
you see the cops come in and taking me I
just brought him to school Oh like I
shamed my mother the whole label you
talk about me to my mother son's a
deeper dive before 1600 of my house and
it better not be if I find out this your
son I might kill or any time for my
stuff got robbed but saying that broke
into they always came to me right yeah
yeah I was a [ __ ] oh my mother had
boyfriend that cut their pockets take
their wallet that's all that did oh you
beat my mother's ass it's my life I
can't help that was a good kid I had to
rob you I had my clothes my [ __ ]
Pumas my Nikes my adidas my skis my
tennis school my [ __ ] sheeps gonna
have to have all that [ __ ] what did it I
was 10
was robbing people how did that make you
feel that that make you feel like you
know had some control or you know how
her fault no it got me respecting the
neighborhood all the older guy told me
to go rob with him never put me in the
wind up with a smaller guy and I will
open the door for them to come in the
house hmm
they would live I was like a celebrity
yeah yeah it gave you friends and people
who look they would come look let me see
your Mikey when that's my house what you
wanted to UM get some money yeah
sometime the older guys have guns and if
somebody said somebody was with their
woman's son and Esmond you always
snatching the guy threatened and they
came up you know that's what it was and
listen it's just what it was if I would
if I didn't do that whoever with nothing
what would I wanna well what was I wanna
hang it was some I want to hang out with
me if I wasn't robbed and making money
helping them get money why would they
want to be with me you had Jumanji pops
with you parents divorced my parents got
divorced was seven and that's worse than
not even having it what did I do to you
personally I became the man in the house
I became you know Mike I had to take
care of everybody and take care of my
brother had to take care of my mom my
mom really struggled with alcoholism for
my childhood was really dark with that
you know with just the people she
brought into the house a lot of violence
a lot of you know wake having to take
care of my brother and then she decided
to move us out to LA so he moved out
here and I was 10 and then
you know she thank god i mean i was such
a beautiful relationship with my mom now
and she's tough as nails and she's you
know 20-plus years sober and we've got a
great relationship and I so feel so
super blessed you know my dad was always
around but he was he was always there
when the after they got divorced we you
know through the custody agreement we'd
spend Wednesday nights with him and then
the weekends with him and football
became my purpose you know so everything
I did was about the up kid yeah I'll
fight my principals I'm gonna fight them
you kicked out of school
that's pretty [ __ ] with you have a fight
high school Mike yeah I'm coming and
public I will fight my principles so
he's just a [ __ ] out of control keno
wild kids only thing I got to do so yes
ma'am no ma'am and I know it I hope my
full no to eat well my mother wants to
look like my parents just because I
pride ego so he knew how to talk yes
ma'am no ma'am
and we know how to eat yeah [ __ ] yeah
other than that important oh my yeah it
was edit edit kick accident make people
think you grew up hey listen I can't
believe how much it helped me am Joe
etiquette yeah it's important it's
important [ __ ]
yes sir is really important that's big I
never knew yes sir yes ma'am no sir no
that is really big mm-hmm oh yeah it's
so big that's big for me you never for
my entire bloody toes were never too big
our county building you never too big to
say those words yeah you had you know
something about that
always showing respect to the people
that you come into contact with it it
goes a long way in your relationship
doesn't it no applet titles in front of
people now saying yes sir yes man was
like a southern here no I do that as
well you know
vampires that fly but in business it
works like [ __ ] and add us respect yeah
cuz the average young adult does that
don't have respect yeah it doesn't it's
a bullet a self that yeah hey how you
doing yeah yeah no I am vegan now got
managed mean she's got man yeah man it
managed take you far I'm telling ya man
big-time education education it's a
device that can control you cuz now if I
educate you with dish subjects and these
words and these numbers now now you
think it's just deep so but yes or no
something I like you onyx everything
about me Ebonics
my lifestyle Ebonics we from the gray
area man you gotta make it legit that's
like I love talking Evonik that's my
strip people like what didn't mean you
got to figure it out tell me tell me
Bonnie
I mean I don't know if I want you to
show me he bought it yeah we feel we got
down like that yeah I understand right
there's Ebonics like if you be like yo u
XY I'm like yeah I got ya over do it
alright babe yeah you know exactly they
show thought we were gonna look 50 years
from now people who how the world would
be 50 years old like what most of us are
gonna be [ __ ] mixed people 50 years
and then I was gonna be mixed like our
kids are gonna be making daughters since
nobody makes probably are your grandkids
will be bloodline but just be probably
it'll be a mix go come on some new
bloodline and make you just live the
siege of thousands like that - that's
what they said - he's gonna live a lot
longer
how long do you really want to live now
that seems you now have what you already
do do I want to live as long as the unit
I want to be in a physical as long as
physicals good I know once you die
that's just the beginning of love of
life oh yeah
can't wait that's just another life I
can't wait man boy you know it is what
it is it is I'm just be a better beard
that's a hot rod but once I learn again
being in his music and everything else
you started you just outdoing yourself
every day then you get to a time and a
point we just want to chill they don't
want to be around people you want to
meditate yeah you want to smoke you just
want to watch with the world hi like I
got to a point in life I just want to
see how air by and in life living hmm
like I literally took a year two years
of my crazies did shows that's the only
time I ever came outside literally
everybody called me no you ought to tell
you out the country I'm just in my house
damn like some people cook a plane bound
for me I was like yo I'm in a future
like it's crazy Mike like I'm actually
in the future if y'all think about all
your friends y'all grew we have from
that hair
technically you in the future absolutely
like like I don't know about nobody else
but I know I've lived in the future and
I'm moving on a different time like I'm
going to pass like I could get off
subject it's like I understand that they
got the letter called the Indians like
the baseball team at the red face that's
[ __ ] that's racist see but I keep going
a lot of things like the Redskins
Redskins like come on my dog that's not
cool yeah you said I'm saying but but
that's now I got a living truth I don't
live in judgment Oh nobody yeah I don't
think it's everybody black is cool
everybody white is cool or it's wrong in
his right if your fucked-up person your
fucked-up person once you know history
you were not ignore facts once I learned
history I respected my elders because
like it's like every L just mean people
that made it is here to see years that
you never seen nice toast my man you all
this [ __ ] he's about this
hey money no matter unique sound 55 you
ain't you don't even know how I feel to
be 55 yeah you think you gonna make it
see 55 hmm
oh did you already say you could never
outdo me I live long it's true like even
humble to where humble will humble me
let's take you I'm puttin serious huh it
means not to take your important serious
so why is it people say humble yourself
well you must they must see that you
think you're more important than what
you are and they would think you need to
be humble people have the wrong person
impression of humble they think humble
means pious well they got to confuse
confused they got humble and pious
confused they think of your humble you
have to be home yes brother yes sister
you think no humble is just not taking
your important serious I'm not being a
big head idiot yeah but back in the day
yeah you know you're not taking in Syria
that's humble these dear invade you yeah
sleep with you wanna kill all the man
and humble you yeah we'll come from
bonus yep in that perspective humbleness
is willingly giving yourself up
not just because somebody's forcing you
to be humble humbleness is willing to be
humble I like playing with the mind
no dude you're [ __ ] what is your kind
of guy bro call mine things we like to
have do to think about crazy [ __ ] like
this like what can I do
I still got conspiracy theories though
please since their show hit us shopping
right now lovely did a trail you're
leading in your boasting hello what do
you think the COS oversee what's your
all right wasn't it white lies in human
and reptiles born and Slava
but what Slava see don'ts got pop the
baby mouth later Bri
I don't know I think I don't know do you
well until you have to cut in the world
they're in water and water yeah then fit
me anymore in phibian than Talent know
they could be ripped out me into the
water it could be right so why we should
be called humanoids and these phones is
called Android I think that another how
long about 40 code is humans with humans
age is no um as of now as of now human
beings have to come to the conclusion
that life is meaningless and death is
inevitable
[Music]
have you read the Emerald tablets what
is that I bet I read outwitting the
devil okay one hell of a book you like
the Emerald tablets
the origins of man from the perspective
of Thoth the Egyptian god of wisdom and
these are Emerald tablets they were and
it's all about how Egypt was formed and
what you said Kemet how that was formed
and that how that came into being
well China booked up well sir my kind of
[ __ ] I just don't think they see the
world is in the book I don't think I
listen I don't think I don't think the
Bible to the corrals I don't think that
can define God no no definitely not only
think we haven't that define God how
does this book how does the book they
have the ending defying God they have an
ending and it's over yeah that's his
word and I'm not disrespecting no book
no Bible or Quran no any book yeah no no
no divinely book but I'm just saying
even it has a million pages have an end
evan is it what is the Bible though at
this point what is it what is it is it
the origins of God knows or without God
or eath from so-called wild white men
and women yeah I had this about losing
five yes instances divided that this
with God you know they're divine yeah
that's what pretty much the book so it's
a record it's a record of phone supplies
yeah interaction I know I know the guy
named King James was all the last black
King really King James was a pause or
more he the last black King I know one
of the biggest heist in Europe the angel
said want like one of the biggest museum
eyes yeah all they stole all of like
more statutes and worth three five no so
what do you think what do you think that
being them or what do you think that's
about
well you know what is about what do you
think being black is about really think
that I'm um I can't be um I don't got
like Creole is not
family so the colored dome acts like
it's although this is honored well I
think what I think man what do you mean
huh
what does that mean figure yourself out
follow you follow your rules find out
your mother's mother's mother oh yeah
figure it out go to your father you can
find yeah I'm big on that I'm digging it
out yeah but I think differently I think
I think um follow those spirits I think
I parents is just sometimes some sub
what do you call that
that's all vessel yeah a portal yeah I
think they had to be born enough for me
to be born yeah somebody my family has
to be born and a little for me them will
live on my kids have to be born and they
kids have to be born even bigger than
ours
their home purpose is dumb the whole
purpose in life like an animal if the
purdue's that's their purpose to eat and
survive no we know it all no animals
that's it they didn't want they had big
egos you became out [ __ ] lion
you think you know [ __ ] of mine you
can't align [ __ ] all day like 50 60
times a day oh yeah absolutely
Tiger difficult day the fur is so tired
lions and tigers they do it oh yeah they
do it all day the Foley - all day
they're ten minutes walk the boom boom
boom five minutes is over but they do
the five minutes all day why Ryan rides
it makes Susan they want to perpetuate
they don't reduce to perpetuate yes
that's a trip they want if it does more
than they want to live right
well living is reproducing
to them that's what most of the time
when people use certain drugs
they get horny yeah that's that that
mind telling them they're getting ready
to die so you need to put those mm-hmm
interesting that's the that's what
horniness us broken down yeah you're
feeling your own mortality maybe your
body is saying it's time to research
learning Mac without you even being
conscious of it that's what the
conscious and unconscious is yeah
without even knowing who this is who we
are sometimes where lives without even
knowing it we tell the truth by accident
sometimes walk what do you uh you want
to shout anything out before we wrap
this up where can you be found that many
projects that you want people know about
oh yeah um 2020 I'm driving flag ability
to my severe anniversary no deal what
[ __ ] hip-hop New York what's your
hip-hop la right no no no no I was on
the show and my wife was on love hit by
a definite had to spoil my queen I got
tired of being a [ __ ] yeah you know
definitely we have to let women I
thought men in general I thought that's
how I'm vulnerable ooh we have to let
women be women yeah that's one of our
biggest mistakes men not letting my
allowed their wife to be women have to
tell they'll always let you need to be
who they are yeah yes so what does and
you have to provide an environment for
them to flourish
you know and vice versa yeah you got to
marry your partner you got four lovely
it's it's true I like that yeah the
third this summer that's it automatic to
love comes late in like I'm later melt
it so far
yeah at the beginning of salt love than
this yeah whoo I'm new and this is the
right to see you made and then we think
it's when that gets old and tired then
you gotta prove you really a man up in
heartbreak though yeah hey when that's
over when all those nothing all that
kissing and all the movies and buying
this and we're traveling with no tie and
now we gotta live now we gotta be human
oh here we are
now we him is now I'm gonna brush your
teeth before you come to bed Mike okay
baby
so true
anybody think I'm a flag I'm a canola
tonight I gotta brush my teeth so true
take a shower tonight baby getting that
shower tonight baby
brush your teeth that's the real world
anybody else was getting don't care
about that no I don't care about it come
on baby push it yeah that's crazy sure
miles I'm like my daughter's like oh yes
you feel amazing
that's the balance and I can't in my
house I can't talk about how many times
I'm working out today I can't talk about
hey yeah I should watch what you eat and
I can't talk nothing about that we're
not talking about thighs when I talking
about good you look at your clothes
we're talking about talking to the kid
how she did today in tennis how was
school today so no more that boss I'm
the boss a but I should look like me
work out hey guys over the world as you
get tired we got kids you know you
anyone [ __ ] that much cool kids give me
a [ __ ]
I gotta take a good dump right now hold
in the 40 you gotta take even before
like now it's all about the humble yield
it's all about the dump good [ __ ] joy
that makes oh I got some [ __ ] a blow to
you like a rocket what is it it's a so
it's a holistic doctor like she got
something called stool cleaner Oh huh
interesting when I tell you cantí kind
of work on these is you ready eight
times clearing it out I bet deeply that
: man yo what is it a drink or
something's powder for me for the school
put in your water
shake it out it's like herbs and [ __ ]
all of it yeah super black don't feel
like you bust a good nut that's good
[ __ ] great [ __ ] it wasn't but
thankfully I don't want to know the baby
was an incredible [ __ ] baby was
incredibly can't believe this you know
people need that bro people need to know
that shit's out there some guys are
sitting around probably having taking a
[ __ ] like an oxygen anyway all the time
if you can't beat them you can't [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] man know when I was overworked
constipate my ass is on fire fast ain't
doing this no more not the way they take
care my ass go clean it oh I guarantee I
love you for who you is I'm gonna know
where it's gonna wake y'all some sleep
like right now I'm telling you what you
doing that like six times in three hours
yeah [ __ ] me
it's cleared out clear out like I'm up
tomorrow
I guarantee does she work I'd try I
don't mean all around the worlds were
SIA she located in the Midwest okay you
want to give her name kids and [ __ ]
brother 14 yo the 14 yard or the I
thought that you'd love and I'll not
love that's my heart she don't see
everything from Charlie is everything to
me right
that's my dog like you know you get a
time raising your kids will you have to
become they first friend hmm
it's deep some I was telling me like how
could you be on you got to be they
parent I said you do but you still have
to be a friend because you have to teach
your friend you're a child with a real
friend is first hmm you see you don't
say
so you when your kids get to a certain
age you can't judge them cuz you don't
know who they bout to become you
actually have to learn who ain't God
them hopefully that they go to that
direction so me and my daughter I just
own children I love like maybe this
world the [ __ ] that my daughter be
seeing in those group chats I'm like
yellow I never I couldn't see this sheet
I was 27
yeah I can be in check that's just not
me my mentality is not good cuz I wanna
[ __ ] the girl when you come up we're
gonna meet you and I'm [ __ ] sick dog
guy I can't be mean no strings our girl
and she's talking hey dude what are you
doing I mean that's not me that's not my
mind work hey would you like to come
over my house I was sure big on my
spread yeah I said my plane to come get
y'all when I had to plain forget it I
was that - didn't I talk about they
should think about though you got a
daughter
yeah I got a girl half girls boy POW
Josie's daughter my oldest daughter is
what 28 now guess what my daughter 14 I
know for a fact there's some little boys
until I thought of that let's you be
like
we easy Oh universe no no because listen
you whatever you put out there comes
back to you that's what the K my mind is
about yo you know I was disrespectful to
the women so I have to expect one day
somebody might be disrespectful to my
daughter and how she mean handling hi
I'm a handle it but I have to look
forward to it coming because I was that
way oh no I'm looking forward to that
one
you know my baby baby Mike I got a whole
birthday cake waiting for I'm telling
you like hey look god bless you know as
you would say if you believe in don't
play with my you got that hey be nice
knees round meter situation some things
are not worth day you have to look at
what happened you know me have to tell
you know what Mike you right but the
male should know I go it ain't even
worth it to do it so you don't he go
you are you I want that respect trust me
I respect every girl who father was like
they don't follow you right on me to go
there and if I did go out to go out with
my with this slave you know this way no
doubt respecting man and I meant it like
a lot of these like like a lot of young
I'm sorry to see it like I did something
we start seeing young girls and he's
young in a young and the younger males
they actually don't be a role models
that should be deep they were all model
be all of you to it social media yeah
because the ones around them too busy
living in it and not being that figure
that you guys seem like that must be my
son watch these two fake gangstas on
YouTube he's been 10 years nine years
old and he's a fake gangs and it's got
the things rep the band down and around
the face he thinks they're great and
funny who heard these are partly college
educated kids and they playing the role
of gang Philly think they're funny and
commenting that should get on my nerves
though cuz I'm jokes will come reality
you know he's becoming your real reality
speaker becoming a reality
I installed the old am I don't unless
you know Martin Lawrence show bill
goddamn living car
all these old-school not just all the
old TV shows that spell card I get I let
us see that [ __ ]
hey Roger hey funnie yeah what they
doing right now this is not free
and so you're gonna have to do your turn
graphical you have to earn your house
and your family you know we just taking
care for a certain period of time then
you're gonna have to go there we got to
prepare you with the skills and you're
gonna have to go out there and do what I
did here out there for yourself and get
your family go do your process of
finding out what kind of made you like
through those years find out make your
fortune get your family and whatever I
taught you about taking care you should
take care of your family in that
perspective of your skills became more
advanced in minds as time went on then
all the best luck for you you know
family skills show we have time go on I
should get better my family skills so
much better than my mother and father's
yeah yeah that's right that's what you
do yeah that part of my family's I think
I've superseded too bad I wasn't tougher
than my father
even though because I'm champion
everybody I'm a bad guy always put those
in the badge man it's fine my father was
a monster he wasn't afraid of nobody
hmm so I can never say because I became
champ I was tougher than I was not
tougher than my father
he's shy they gonna shoot off the cops
and all laughter that is just too deep
and too extreme for me because I had me
one more successful to them doesn't mean
I'm a better man than him
even though he had his faults and stuff
and I'm a different kind of person
didn't ever but it's no way to I think I
was tougher than him I feel that anyway
ya know if I went to jail on a standoff
with the Polli
yeah yes I meant was a younger guy in my
20s women and men used to come and tell
me about this stuff for my father his
old prostitutes and stuff to tell me
about my school I said well I'm not like
him at all
okay I'll do the courageous mm-hmm don't
want to somebody talking that bad [ __ ]
but I don't want to be like him I don't
think I want that [ __ ] I'm gonna raise
my kids and since he grandkids and stuff
it's a good convo mill now watch sports
I'm not sports guy a little bit i watch
the fights and stuff on what too much
MMA yeah oh yeah Overeem oh yeah it was
tough it was pretty nasty that's what
happens in fighting when that meant to
our bodies and I meant to be be done I
followed every day and the me too but
that's not a whole correct that's not
what our family our body's made to do I
hang a lot my mom helped her out that's
right every [ __ ] show
it was me spitting at you throwing [ __ ]
[ __ ] ain't got to put in some work shoot
us ain't flexing even like it wasn't
[ __ ] you just try my ego was at its
all-time high when I was younger younger
ACC 78 79 um everybody listen to the
music when we put the two turntables
outside to play in the parking stuff
everybody to listen to that music was
all the same they were dissing friend if
infection we were all the same kind of
people and we all looked out for one
another because we knew the cops were
against as we know some older guys would
like to stick us up the law but they
were big in us we all with friends we
all looked out for each other cuz we
were all moneymakers and we knew people
without to get us besides the law so we
had to worry about the older people
robbing us from the money that we
robbing from people and then we have to
worry about the cops be nice and they
don't feel like ways they don't feel
like doing paperwork they have take all
your money that's kick your ass let's
get out of here
cops take your money take your jury
take your jury they see even Rolex a
10-year killer Rolex or long gene Watson
taking with you to kill swings you watch
a jury
because we were young kid I used to wear
a people wear the jury that we stole and
people walking by I mean where do you
get that far whoa groan for him yeah
where do you get that pump what do you
mean
my brother let me use this and I think
no I didn't pay for this I'm a little
kid I just wanna take off take old
cameras yeah no problem people haven't
been to my house wrong and somebody's
talking I'm like what
and somebody I said what he thinks I'm
somebody who I don't know who II thought
I would be thought I musta came back in
the house or something and I got after
house we took off I was announcer
concerning summer thing hey baby you're
ready everything okay you're ready back
yeah [ __ ] man that's it
let's see the dog and Miata just tired
I'm from the king adult seat now you
advance at my first time smoking weed
out yeah crazy but look back at that
person like Dan could you imagine your
son being a no I can't man my friend my
daughter right now it's going win a bus
or some wind tightening it going
somebody some stranger's pocket no chain
and hey they're gonna chase him listen
sometimes when you snatch some pocket a
change you get a hero out of the blue
they start chasing you for the person
and he's gotta fight somehow now you
fighting for somebody and you're
fighting the next thing you know more
people are coming get that money's
waiting we're fighting this by gathering
that we pick up a shammy runner and move
and then we running through and we run
to see me run through the Chinese
neighborhood the Chinese people don't
[ __ ] I was doing trying to get us and we
got that [ __ ] money when I stopped
him boy we're not stopping
the whole [ __ ] town [ __ ] chasing the
Italian the tape then you run through
you go to China time the Chinese he
running to the Italian station in a
chase after you and everybody's chasing
the [ __ ] [ __ ] baby everything one of
us could be the Puerto Ricans with us
too and whoever's running it we got the
money with the package they on the man
you got to see the honors we've run it
not even our neighbor we don't even know
what everyone do the it's one I'll run
them till they get tired we don't even
know where we're running in different
neighborhood different ethnic maybe
we'll be running through the
neighborhood and they start chasing us -
we jump on a bus the buses go and then
we are the [ __ ] people don't borrow
that as artists [ __ ] is crazy
that New York not even ease New York
isn't know how that felt
no I need another I'm telling that when
I lived in New York I grew up with bus
passes every month to the point where I
should get on a city bus each be that
one you want to be a bishop from juice
yo on the bus like yellow yeah everybody
try to take you back I took a lot of
path
I picked our people got the bus pass
free my cousin it wasn't for my cousin
Kay Kay
I swear yeah it took me and my little
brother bus pass everybody was like [ __ ]
we're gonna break it he's gonna bust -
pickpocketing wrong people
we're coming the bus real early I'll
stop train and we start opening the
windows next to the seats the people you
guys sit down like this and the windows
there so I opened all the 1/3 my favor
and all the windows and we s wait for
people to see there and help sometime
before people sitting next to the window
with a chain or something I make my
payments or something and so we get off
the bus to change the bus they're going
we just put a handle and that's the
chain out then we showing the chain that
plus the chain goes by oh my god
master master is my life it's crazy the
thought process chasing you old God in
the carpet that chase you before him
couldn't catch you and then you walk
your children on like two days a week
later than he had coming
chuckling slows you on the ground and
put eggs up so they remember me we can
feel a leak ready slams on the floor
remember me a black pastor you remember
me huh
you got random you got tired or
something that's for you a week later
beat your ass like Elvis money I did
some fucked-up [ __ ] like that I always
just lay down some reason we would do
crazy go be online
I'm lying right now I just can't a PD
put my hands on you in the game they're
gonna get too perfect I found that one
time they never forget tonight Wayne
County though claim County never forget
your face one day I went to court and I
had a mask my friend was going to quote
but I was going to court downstairs in
another room so I came upstairs when I'm
breaking I went upstairs to see my
friends court case and I was around 11
and the cop can't have him ski mask on
the cop kept coming by looking at me
Kevin looking at me right and then I
went down and then they say you know I
was in I was back in New York on that
block that weeps flop and still stuff
and the car was Danny he looked at me
said you don't have your mask with you
today do you
I said [ __ ] he found out who I was I
remember that you have your math today
do you
oh yes my total me but that's we had
beef with the cops maybe shoot asthma it
was just that's crazy
we were just kids - yeah dude you were
ten yeah Jesus little bit robbed the
Pepsi truck either the Pepsi truck comes
in the parking that we robbed the took
the guys nobody had his money in the
shoe pockets snatched away I was pocket
he knew where they had he went dig it
out the car in the neighborhood oh if he
got out of the car he all
he wondered he just kept stayed in the
car you don't get out the car because
once they got the car they station if
finish the truck is gone they're
sleeping on the floor it's over because
sometimes you know is just a free foot
but it's looking this victim stuff and I
go glass snatching know everybody in the
block is chasing me they want to take
this cup from me I just keep it moving I
jump in the cab I was just a while with
a kid you're pretty savvy Mike they
gotta say hey Lou you knew its strategy
you knew where to go I learned from
those guys in the streets they taught me
everything I watched him and they told
me everything so interesting and I look
at myself now afterwards pride to still
hmm Oh take advantage of somebody I
think that's beneath me now isn't that a
trip that was my life I couldn't live
without taking advantage of anybody my
mother's friends anybody a mother friend
we get their welfare check I go in their
house I go me and my friends we go there
and we probably take the food at the
fridge we take everything and they
downstairs drinking with my mother
we was just that's just who we were that
was a mentality we were the uncounseled
and anyway I thought we were great for
everybody looked up to us for it you
know you the guy uses a geek you went to
school you're a sucker people snatched
you change smack your glasses off affect
you unless you have a big brother son
the people respect they just won't
bother you but they don't mess with you
either they don't respect you he's a fox
yeah that she still exists absolutely it
half of the day with me half if it
doesn't change you then every aspect of
life though yeah
you now many people not kill themself
over that and I never remember anybody
killed himself over getting a speeder
ripped off even sexually abused but now
that I happen to be automatically called
suicide his world like I think they said
I think it's sixty four thousand people
attempt suicide every day yeah but
that's um that's an interesting thing
Raffi foods hello welcome in suicides
well some people some people a mentally
strong enough people fight things that's
I don't know I think something I think
that's very strong it's all for you
survive not too many people but in the
same right it's a bad [ __ ] thing
missing that they can't do that but it
is same in the same prep I can see oh
yes the toughest I don't I don't look
down on anybody to do that I think
that's the author I think that's a form
of life that you know if that's what I
fit the woman is to die you know some
people more attuned to it than others
that's just some people want to with it
they understand they understand the
elements more they think they're doing
another fear but it's just difficult and
I'm soon as we born death fits calling
us we die in that second every tenth of
a second retiring we can older leaves
and stuff you know still we're afraid
that that you know this is natural this
is well suppose this is what the
universe expect from us to happen and
still we want it we want to live it over
longer and longer and longer this is
what is expect was is bigger than us
that is bigger than enough that's like
this big of is enough I mean what is
death or at least watch this one what if
you took fear out of the book what is
death I never for my life but if you
have no fear why are you worrying about
death well some people don't have
anything what about if you take poverty
in fear out of the equation for
everybody in the world was life now well
we're fine threaten us to be bitching
about the final another exponent to make
an issue that's what the brain do who
wants to survive it doesn't want to die
either we have to prepare ourself for
death
a deaf actor hideth unexpectantly
quickly but if it's a if it's the
process of dying we're gonna go through
emotions if it takes probably a couple
of months or a year to the divers gonna
go through the certain waves of emotion
during that process of my death so I'm
gonna feel so I foresaw someone go to
yes do interpret perspective on our life
that we remember remember then we come
accustomed EF mean God I think it's a
good place to end this thing absolutely
with Waka Flocka man thank you for
coming to stay at when you out here
lastly yeah friends house yeah alright
so it's good I believe that no I knew
I'd find it when I was busted and have
no much money I'm [ __ ] fun on me
friends I had hmm you know the [ __ ] and
I found that listen and when I found out
how many friends I had [ __ ] said [ __ ]
this [ __ ] I ain't doing nothing yeah I
got me [ __ ] on what's that word again
we had no interest when you said I'm
doing this different yeah they doing all
this stuff for me I gave a [ __ ] to
caught up with it I didn't want to do
nothing hurt hurt with their life you
know I had to come back to earth to live
my life
mmm you know according to my life and my
stance at that time yeah you know I
found that my friends helping me so much
hindered me so much
it's hinder method it does so much much
so earlier if I then let the enemy with
their kindness yeah I understand that
thank you buddy that helps you not
defend anybody fight it's not your enemy
yeah yeah I had such a good time that
you bought your the man do your thing
it's been it's awesome lots of respect
any final shoutouts everybody where they
can follow you find you shout out to
freedom and my wife my mother my
brothers and a band
bimmy an artist the whole family yeah
brother
well great show Mike Hollies man this
was a great one one of my favorite New
York yeah I love da range guy from
Tennessee or something we got a company
in Nashville yeah we got a hemp grow out
there so alright everybody thanks for
Jim in this episode of hot boxing with
Mike Tyson I'm Evan Brittany and I'm
Mike Tyson out of here now once they
thin the [ __ ] you finish
[Music]
[Music]